[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a este nuevo
programa de los observadores aquí en
france24 para esta última entrega de
nuestra temporada volveremos a ver tres
temas que marcaron este año en torno a
iniciativas innovadoras en la red social
dictó esta popular plataforma inspiró a
tres de nuestros observadores que
realizaron vídeos para hablar de los
temas que los motivan estos niños viven
en un campo de desplazados sus familias
huyeron de los combates entre el régimen
sirio y los grupos rebeldes casi
1.400.000 personas en campamentos como
este en el norte de silla algunos desde
el comienzo del conflicto hace 10 años
[Música]
así que para dar a conocer sus vidas un
activista sirio decidió publicar vídeos
en tick tock la aplicación tick tock se
ha convertido en una de las más
populares del mundo es una forma muy
eficaz de difundir vídeos debemos
utilizar todos los medios posibles para
informar sobre las condiciones de vida
del pueblo sirio y muchos desplazados
cuando se dieron cuenta de que iban a
estar en los campamentos durante mucho
tiempo empezaron a construir casas con
piedras que encontraban en el campo
tan solo construyen paredes y un techo
rudimentario con trozo de lona para
mejorar un poco la vida cotidiana de sus
familias
[Música]
últimamente ha habido muchos incendios
por desgracia por eso una ong local ha
organizado clases para que los
desplazados estén preparados para apagar
un incendio rápidamente en muchos
campamentos las tiendas de campaña se
han convertido en aulas ya que hay pocas
escuelas y muchos niños en estos
campamentos en estas escuelas no hay
sillas ni tableros los profesores dan
clases gratuitas
[Música]
el bar
para víctor es también un medio para que
las minorías denuncien la discriminación
y las ideas preconcebidas sobre ellas
este es el caso de las personas
discapacitadas como james ward una
parapléjica británica que nos explicó su
propuesta
cuando empecé él no había casi nadie que
hiciera vídeos sobre la discapacidad
diría de éstos
me parece que el hashtag silla de ruedas
tenía 11 publicaciones en instante
hoy creo que superamos de largo las
100.000 publicaciones
[Música]
[Aplausos]
inicialmente dictó había impedido que el
contenido de las personas con
discapacidad apareciera en vídeos
sugeridos en otras palabras su contenido
tenía muy pocas posibilidades de ser
ampliamente visto tick tock quería
proteger a sus usuarios con discapacidad
de ser objeto de acoso de plataforma a
cabo disculpándose y cambiando su
política pero este episodio dejó un
sabor amargo en la boca de nuestras
observadoras tenía miedo de utilizar
ciertos hashtags como discapacitados
silla de ruedas lesión medular que
necesito usar si quiero que la gente
encuentre mi contenido pero obviamente
tenía miedo de usarlos porque tenía que
tick tock no destacar el contenido que
me había esforzado en realizar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
con este tipo de vídeos ludovic francés
che un recolector de basura parisino se
ha convertido en una estrella tick tock
donde tiene más de 140 mil suscriptores
un trabajo del que dice estar orgulloso
y que cobraba mayor importancia con la
pandemia de kobe 19 especialmente en el
pasado otoño cuando cerraron los
restaurantes en francés todo el mundo
tome el aire libre lo que algunos hacen
como si se les olvidará su bolsa de
comida rápida cuando se levantan o ponen
el pretexto de que el bote de basura que
les queda cerca está lleno cuando no
tardarían ni dos minutos en ir a otro
bote vacío un poco más lejos no entiendo
me imagino que piensan no importa los
recolectores de basura lo recogen
[Música]
la mayoría de la gente cuando come se
mete la mascarilla en el bolsillo y
luego las mascarillas de encaje es falta
de atención y así acabamos con una masa
de mascarillas por todas partes
todo lo que son servilletas de papel
vasos de plástico todo eso sale volando
y luego va a parar a todas partes así
que terminan los árboles
y esto es un nido miren lo que hay en él
es plástico estos pájaros construyeron
sus nidos alrededor de ese plástico es
impresionante debemos utilizar estos
famosos contenedores para depositar
nuestros residuos cualquiera que sea
los residuos domésticos en este y en
este todo lo reciclable una vez que
estén en los botes nosotros lo enviamos
a donde corresponde
y hasta aquí llega esta última edición
de esta temporada de los observadores en
france24 pero nos vemos muy pronto con
nuevas ediciones mientras tanto no dude
en enviarnos sus fotos y vídeos
aficionados para contarnos lo que ocurre
cerca de usted todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla hasta pronto
ah